I'm embarrassed
whenever my short-term actions don't
align with my long-term values and I
think that is really the root of
embarrassment
[Music]
tkm got some talk aboutables for you
let's talk about it I'm embarrassed by
this oh my my little jingle
I was kind of insecure about it so
thanks for the validation Bama what are
you embarrassed about
I'm embarrassed
whenever my short-term actions don't
align with my long-term values and I
think that is really the root of
embarrassment
yes it's possible to get
embarrassed because I woke up naked in
the middle of somewhere and all of a
sudden
well maybe I value being perceived a
certain way we get embarrassed by a
bunch of absurd things that aren't
really embarrassing I get the I'm
terrified of public speaking because of
the humiliation aspect I'm terrified of
being buck naked in public because of
the humiliation aspect but then we get
humiliated by all these other things
what if someone doesn't like my shirt
all of a sudden I'm embarrassed by
something I wasn't embarrassed by five
minutes ago because someone laughed at
my haircut right I'm embarrassed because
of what and so I think that there are so
many things that we latch on to that
we're doing with our time
that don't comport with the best version
of ourselves and so whenever I feel like
I'm embarrassed whenever I feel that
embarrassment take me over and I'd be
interested how
our audience perceives this as well when
you think about the last time you were
embarrassed what did it involve let me
know in the comments because I find it
really interesting and it probably
involves something and TK I'd love to
hear your thoughts on this maybe there's
an additional perspective I'm not seeing
but it probably involves like I'm not
behaving right now doing what I want to
do right now or abstaining from what I
want to abstain from right now because
the best version of me would be doing
something different and I become
embarrassed when there's an observer of
that someone else is observing the
misalignment of my actions and the
person I want to be
so what if I'm embarrassed because maybe
somebody's laughing at me
um you know I'm walking down the street
and I see you hey Josh what's up and
then I trip and fall and there are some
kids who see me trip and fall and
they're like hahaha you complete dork
and I feel embarrassed break that down
how does that work into what you're
saying yeah I think that's spot on so
what happens is I don't want to be
perceived as the type of person who
would make such a Clum clumsy gesture I
would trip and fall you notice this in
kids all the time if you have a little
kid who's like I remember when Ella was
three and she would hurt herself she'd
bang her arm on something or she'd trip
and fall and the first thing she would
do is look up to see what her response
should be
and so if I would say oh are you okay oh
I'm so sorry then she starts crying but
if I just look at her and say ah
it goes and she moves on because she her
response is a mirror of my response
there right and what you're saying is I
value what that other person thinks in
that scenario when they saw me trip
they thought that I was lesser a lesser
human being
but the truth is like we all trip
metaphorically and literally and so why
be embarrassed about it at all
so that sensation of embarrassment is an
opportunity for me to say hey why does
it embarrass me It embarrasses me
because I want to be respected by others
as a person that's in control as a
person that's smooth and wouldn't do
something so clumsy and then you can go
a little deeper well
what do I really want there I want to be
a person who's in control of my
disposition such that even if I fall I
still feel cool and it's unwavering even
when other people laugh yeah and then
you value a few things and you have to
start questioning why do I value those
things yeah now two of those that you
just mentioned that I value and to me
they're types of Personality clutter for
me one is I need to be respected okay
well why what do I actually get out of
that well people like me more okay what
do I get out of that and as you begin to
interrogate it the whole ball of yarn
unravels and you realize how absurd it
is to need to be respected yeah I listen
to podcasts you know Nori uh from CNN he
uh not not the news network okay no no
yeah Capone Noriega CNN that's CNN not
the news network anyway he uh he was a
hip-hop artist who has a really popular
podcast now called drink Champs one of
the questions they ask people every
episode there's like these dualities
would you choose respect or loyalty and
I always hearing these answers crack me
up because needing either one of those
becomes a prison yeah if I need malabama
to be loyal to me yeah now all of a
sudden I'm contorting myself to make her
be loyal or let's say I do something
that's just completely out of step and
out of alignment with who she is as a
person expecting her to Then Fall follow
me there is disingenuous I become now
I'm dragging her because of some faux
loyalty right and I think the same is
true with respect right and so needing
those things it's fine to get respect
it's fine to have someone who's loyal to
you there's no problem with that but as
soon as I need them I've imprisoned
myself and then I start behaving
differently and no wonder we start to
feel embarrassed the other thing that I
often cling to is the desire to be cool
right because a cool person would never
trip like that James Dean wouldn't now
of course James Dean tripped like that
right I don't know man that's cool bro
it probably would make it look cool some
kind of way all right how about this I'm
trying to think Bama gets what I'm
saying who's a portion of cool right now
um LeBron James
trips from time to time nah uh
Denzel is smooth yes everything from how
he drinks a cup of coffee whatever
everything he does is smooth right
that's our James Dean at least to me in
that respect I totally agree especially
like training day era Denzel Washington
right but now as you see him as he gets
older he's willing to make those flubs
but even because it's Denzel those flubs
are cool yeah his missteps are cool he
embodies coolness in a way so coolness
doesn't have to do whether or not I
tripped or what do I do with that trip
yeah and and you get the impression that
his coolness doesn't come from the world
crowning him as the king of cool but it
comes from a place of self-acceptance
there are some people who are just so
sure of themselves so confident that
they make you sure you know that's right
yeah and so it can become contagious
insecurity is contagious but also that
sense of certainty that self-certainty
is also contagious and so that means
that coolness is actually a byproduct
and if you need to be cool you ever seen
the people who try to affect coolness
it's like that Steve Buscemi meme which
we'll get Danny to put up on the video
version of the screen right now where
it's like hey fellow kids and he's like
carrying a skateboard and it's like oh
my stars he's trying to be cool right so
hard and we call we even have a name for
that we call those people tryhards
but then when you see Denzel Washington
feels effortless we call it effortless
by the way there's a version of this I
experience in my work with high school
students whenever someone new enters the
space there is a predictable fear about
making sure they're cool everyone is
afraid of high school students am I cool
enough for them will they like me
everyone's paranoid and it's it's
absolutely amazing because people seem
to think that 16 year olds don't know
any 60 year olds the 16 year olds don't
have to get along every single day with
older people that they don't think are
cool and so when you walk into a
classroom and you start trying to act
out whatever you think is Young and cool
pretending like you understand things
that you don't they see right through
you and they resist you because
everybody is repulsed by a lack of
authenticity everyone is repulsed by
fake but when you walk into the
classroom and you're like look I'm 70
I'm 50 I'm 40. I have no idea what you
guys are listening to I have no idea
look at what I'm wearing I'm not cool
but this is what we're going to talk
about today and I'm super excited about
it let me tell you why they receive it
because people receive authenticity it's
not that they want cool they want
authentic and authentic is actually what
looks cool which is why everybody has
people in their lives that they think
are cool that are completely different
from one another
yeah it's fascinating because cool is
also in the eye of the beholder and so
what you're saying is just because you
don't conform to a trend you don't walk
into a school you're not like rapping
gonna lyrics because you could do that
and maybe you could even do that
authentically right I would get kicked
out if I tried that that's also true
yeah but a lot of people they would see
you as being hyper uncool because you're
like here's this 40-something-year-old
guy and these two things they're
incongruous right but then you can go in
there and you can command a room and
start talking about some things that
matter all of a sudden now you're that
cool older guy not because you're trying
to conform to their lifestyle and what
is trendy to them because you've pulled
them into your world and someone can
still think you're uncool I mean there
are people who don't know who Denzel
Washington is now which is wild right
yeah I was in the dentist chair the
other day and uh this young uh uh Dental
Tech she came up and she's a do you know
who you look like and I'm like yeah I
get all the time you're Christopher
Walken she's like who
what she was like no I Denzel Washington
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and I'm like yeah Christopher walk she's
like I'd have to Google him I'm like oh
yeah that's true I mean she was probably
25 years old 23 years old maybe she
doesn't know who Christopher Walken is
now he transcends a lot of generations
he's almost 80 years old so he's well
beyond my generation but people often
say I look like Christopher she says no
you look like Johnny Bravo
you know I've labeled something for you
and said I think I put it down discount
Johnny Bravo one time we had stuff in
the writer's room for you I was labeling
everything with just silly names for
people and I used Johnny Bravo for you
for your hair well I'm sure Danny put uh
pictures of both Christopher Walken and
Johnny Bravo off of the screen so you
can compare
tell me uh what you think in the
comments hey I hope you enjoyed that
highlight clip from the minimalist
private podcast if you'd like to see the
full maximal episode plus more be sure
to check us out on patreon the link is
in the description patreon is what helps
us keep this podcast 100 advertisement
free if you're not yet ready for that
check out another video
[Music]
foreign